Transcriptor: Mayca Onega
Revisor: Almudena Torrecilla
La paradoja de la diversidad es sumamente
sencilla y compleja de entender a la vez.
Todos somos iguales precisamente
porque somos diferentes.
La belleza de la diversidad
es que no existimos dos personas,
dos seres humanos que seamos idénticos.
Todos somos únicos e irrepetibles.
Tan sencillo como eso.
Son los elementos como:
raza, etnia, nacionalidad, edad, religión,
orientación sexual, identidad de género,
y la lista puede seguir
hasta incluir si crees o no crees
en “moggles” (moguris).
Así somos de divertidos los seres humanos.
Encontramos “n” cantidad de formas
de diferenciarnos los unos de los otros.
Pero ahí viene la parte interesante.
Esta idea que parece tan sencilla,
tan trivial, que no tiene importancia,
ha sido la base de las peores catástrofes
y las peores desgracias
en la historia de la humanidad.
Si nos damos cuenta, el no entenderlo
es lo que ha generado muchísimos problemas
entre las personas.
Y esta idea, si la entendemos
y la interiorizamos,
puede cambiarnos completamente.
Ahora les tengo que hacer una confesión.
Por mucho tiempo, a mí
no me importó el tema de la diversidad.
Y ¿por qué?
Sencillamente porque no me afectaba.
Sencillamente porque
no me afectaba de manera negativa.
Y ahí yo poco a poco
tuve que ir entendiendo
muchísimas cosas a lo largo de la vida.
Primero, todos los días yo veía
las señales que ahí estaban.
Lo veía en una mujer
que tenía que trabajar el doble
para que se le reconociera
la mitad que a un hombre.
Lo veía en cualquier persona
que no podía amar abiertamente
porque amaba al género equivocado
según la sociedad.
Lo veía con cualquier persona
que se enfrentaba
a una barrera física o actitudinal.
Era sumamente complejo,
y lo peor de todo era que yo pensaba
que era una persona inclusiva,
cuando a veces no lo era.
¿Por qué?
Porque creía en prejuicios
y en estereotipos.
Repetía frases que ahora
me parecen chocantes como:
“Juega como (una) niña”.
“Habla como (una) niña”.
“Pega como (una) niña”.
Sin darme cuenta de qué era lo que
yo estaba realmente queriendo decir.
Entonces, hay algo sumamente importante
con lo que tenemos que empezar.
Tenemos que definir qué es diversidad.
Y diversidad es quizá una de las palabras
más difíciles de definir,
por una razón sencilla,
porque cada quien la define
según sus vivencias y sus experiencias.
No todas las personas incluyen los mismos
elementos de diversidad en esta palabra.
Y aquí tenemos que entender algo,
dos palabras sumamente sencillas,
y aprender a diferenciarlas:
“normal” versus “común”.
“Normal”, si Uds. lo revisan
en la Real Academia Española,
tiene cuatro definiciones,
pero son dos las que me interesan.
La primera: “Que sirve
como norma o parámetro”.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Que si es parte de la mayoría,
entonces es considerado normal.
Pero la segunda definición
es la que más me encanta:
“Algo que sucede en su estado natural
o que sucede dentro de la naturaleza”.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Si algo sucede dentro
de la naturaleza, es normal.
No importa que no sea común.
Y esa es la definición
que tenemos que hacer.
La distinción que tenemos que hacer.
No es lo mismo “normal” versus “común”.
Y yo no sé Uds., yo no quiero ser
una persona común, pero soy normal.
Ahora, aquí también tenemos que entender
algo sumamente importante.
A todos nos afecta y todos vivimos
a la sombra de la inclusión y la equidad,
nos demos o no nos demos cuenta.
Y aquí hay algo sumamente importante.
Inclusión es que todos
queremos ser parte de algo.
Y equidad es que queremos
que se nos trate con justicia.
Y la pregunta que todos nos hacemos es:
Si tengo los elementos
correctos de diversidad,
¿Tengo de qué preocuparme?
Y la respuesta es sí,
tienen mucho de qué preocuparse.
Les pongo un ejemplo.
En Wall Street, Uds. pueden tener
el tono de piel adecuado,
pero si no tienen el género adecuado,
la vida se les va a complicar muchísimo.
Según The Economist,
de las 500 empresas de Fortune 500
solamente 10 son lideradas
por mujeres CEO.
El tema de diversidad sexual
ha sido documentado
desde hace más de 5200 años de historia,
cuando fue escrita la primera
novela épica, el Gilgamesh,
y lo pueden buscar ahí.
Desde ahí se documenta
la diversidad sexual.
La homosexualidad existe
en más de 450 especies.
Y según varios estudios,
entre el 8 y el 12 % de la población
pertenece a la población LGBTI.
No obstante, la homosexualidad
está penada por ley en más de 70 países,
según la ILGA, y en 11 con pena de muerte.
Si queremos continuar
con los temas de diversidad,
pensemos en las personas con discapacidad.
Según la ONU, el 15 %
de las personas en el mundo,
mil millones de personas,
tienen algún tipo de discapacidad.
Y viven el 80 % en países
en vías de desarrollo.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Que viven en sociedades
donde no se les incluye
y donde se enfrentan a barreras físicas
y actitudinales todos los días.
Y aquí yo les quiero hacer una pregunta:
¿Cuántos de ustedes
se han sentido discriminados
en algún momento de sus vidas?
Levanten la mano, por favor.
Perfecto.
Quien no la haya levantado, no le creo.
Todos hemos vivido
en algún momento la discriminación.
Y aquí les hago la segunda pregunta:
¿Cómo se sintieron?
¿Cuál es la primera palabra
que les viene a la mente?
¿Rabia? ¿Enojo? ¿Impotencia?
Por supuesto.
Y aquí viene un problema.
Todo el mundo normalmente me dice:
“Ramón, lo viví sólo una vez.
Por lo tanto, no me afecta”.
Perfecto.
Pero, ¿qué pasa cuando esto es sistémico?
¿Cuando esto lo vives
todos los días de tu vida
y tienes miedo de salir a la calle porque
puedes ser víctima de un crimen de odio?
El sistema te niega educación,
te niega vivienda
y te niega acceso a trabajos
por el color de piel o tu orientación.
Es complicado.
Poco a poco lo fui viendo.
No solo con la gente cercana a mí,
sino que poco a poco fui viendo
cómo esto iba sucediendo en todo el mundo.
Y ahí, me di cuenta de algo.
Tuve este “aha moment” y me di cuenta
de que no solo hemos sido discriminados,
sino que también todos hemos discriminado.
Algunos lo hacen de manera consciente,
creyendo en ideas tan tontas,
como por ejemplo, el tema de la raza.
Raza, antiguamente, se utilizaba
para definir grupos étnicos
que compartían una cultura,
un lugar donde ellos vivían o una lengua.
No como lo conocemos ahora,
que es algo fisiológico.
El término raza, como lo conocemos ahora,
empieza en el siglo XVII,
cuando empieza la taxonomía
con Carl Linnaeus,
y lo empiezan a utilizar los europeos
para justificar algo:
la esclavitud y el horror que eso traía.
Ahora, muchos también lo hacemos
de manera inconsciente.
¿Por qué?
Porque todos los seres humanos
tenemos un elemento
que se llama el sesgo inconsciente,
que son atajos mentales
que nosotros tenemos.
Son atajos mentales que nos han ayudado
a sobrevivir como especie
durante los últimos cien mil años.
Y esos atajos mentales
ahorran energía al cerebro.
Un sesgo inconsciente le ahorra
o consume 200 mil veces menos energía
que un pensamiento consciente.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Que todos somos susceptibles
a los sesgos de primera impresión,
somos susceptibles
a los sesgos de confirmación,
pero también somos susceptibles
a los estereotipos y a los prejuicios.
Todos los tenemos.
Son inconscientes y el problema
es cuando no somos conscientes
de lo inconscientes que podemos ser.
Ahora, no es necesario tener que vivir
las consecuencias de la discriminación,
de la exclusión, para entender
que algo no está bien.
No es necesario ser
una mujer en Wall Street
para darte cuenta de las injusticias
que se están dando.
No es necesario tener que estar
en una silla de ruedas
para entender la barrera
que puede ser una grada.
Es tan sencillo,
que hay que entender que la inclusión
puede traer muchísimos beneficios,
pero la idea parece ser tan compleja
que no la queremos entender.
Entre estos beneficios,
como sociedad, por ejemplo,
podemos crear muchísima innovación
y podemos tener muchísima creatividad.
Y no es casualidad, por ejemplo,
que los centros innovadores
y creativos más importantes del mundo,
Nueva York, Londres y Singapur,
son los centros que han sabido
utilizar la diversidad
y de alguna manera amalgamarla.
Segundo, como empresas, las empresas
que logran gestionar la diversidad,
según un estudio de McKinsey,
son entre 15 y 33 % más rentables.
Pero a nivel personal,
la valía que nosotros sentimos
cuando somos parte de algo
y tratados con justicia;
lo que nosotros podemos crear
cuando somos parte de algo
y lo plenos que podemos llegar a ser,
no tiene valor.
La pregunta es:
¿Cómo podemos ser más inclusivos?
Sencillo.
Primero: tratemos de volver conscientes
nuestros sesgos inconscientes.
No es fácil, pero se puede.
Segundo:
Cuando encontremos que estamos
teniendo prejuicios o estereotipos,
tratemos de desactivarlos.
¿Y cómo se puede hacer? Sencillo.
Educación, educación, educación.
Y solo con este tipo de educación,
nosotros vamos a lograr darle
un nuevo giro a la frase:
“Juega como (una) niña”.
Y empezar a entender que “jugar como niña”
significa jugar como Serena Williams,
o “hablar como niña”
significa hablar como Gabriela Mistral.
Hay que darles ese nuevo sentido.
Y tercero:
tratemos de practicar la tolerancia,
pero aspiremos al verdadero respeto.
No es fácil.
Vamos a fallar de vez en cuando,
pero tenemos que entender algo.
Hablar de diversidad, inclusión y equidad
no es hablar únicamente de una minoría,
es hablar de Uds., es hablar de mí,
es hablar de todos nosotros.
Todos somos seres humanos.
Todos somos únicos e irrepetibles.
Todos somos la paradoja de la diversidad
y tenemos que entender eso.
Los grandes cambios
empiezan con las pequeñas ideas.
Y entender esta pequeña idea,
sencilla pero poderosa,
es sembrar la semilla para que
las sociedades se vuelvan más inclusivas,
y cada uno de nosotros podamos ser
plenos y felices en nuestras vidas.
Gracias.